and the thing is this right people are
going to say the things that they want
to say about Trump the point is this he
doesn't Biden has not faced the same
level of scrutiny that Trump did if you
if we had Trump's family right involved
in all the nefarious acts that the Biden
families involved in do what Shady deals
with Dinah with China accepting money
from foreign Nationals
um all these shell companies
[Music]
yeah if all this stuff was associated
with with Trump they would have buried
him further but you don't see the
mainstream media covering that with all
the nefarious links to the Biden
organization oh my God bro if it was a
doc if it was a Donald Trump Junior
laptop well under it would be over
smoking crack underage Chinese girls all
the are you kidding me bro
dude you want to know how I know that
they just have a hard on for Trump or
they're trying to get him on anything
they indicted him up in New York and I
don't know if you were going to talk
about this stop me if you guys were they
didn't add them up in New York Alvin
Bragg attorney general out there went
ahead and indicted him for falsifying
business records which by the way guys
is a [__] misdemeanor okay but they
went ahead and hit him with the felony
because they think it's going to be be
in furtherance of a felony which I'm
looking at my head like wait he paid off
a porn star uh his attorney and already
ended up getting charged for that
federally Etc whatever now the state of
New York and that's what Alvin Brad
campaigned under by the way I'm gonna go
after Trump I'm going to go after Trump
and the best he could do was a
falsifying business records which is
typically a misdemeanor charge but he
went ahead and tried to enhance it to
the felony on site of oh it's a
furtherance of another crime which I
think they might try to use the uh you
know donating to a campaign over
exceeding the funds as the subsequent
crime which doesn't make sense because
that's a federal crime that's a whole
other thing but they just have a hard on
from you know the the lawsuit right
which I actually read the lawsuit on air
it's written as a novel it's not written
as a legal document it's literally I
want you guys go on Pace or it looks
like 50 Shades of Gray type things
literally a 50 Shades a great thing and
the woman that made the allegations
basically her strong her case was on her
testimony and two other witnesses that
she called right after the act so and
everyone's running around saying Trump
is guilty of sexual assault no he was
found liable in a civil court it is not
the same thing preponderance of the
evidence as a far smaller burden than it
is beyond a reasonable doubt but the
court of me you know public opinion
wants you to say oh you got convicted of
sexual assault no that is not true he
was found liable and it doesn't take
much proof in a civil case to prove 51
versus 49 essentially
did you did you see the the interview
with the lady with Anderson Cooper says
so were you physically raped oh my God
no listen rape is not physical
rape can be emotional rape can be and
Anderson Cooper have you seen this or no
yeah I haven't seen this but it sounds
can you please find that clip do you
know which one I'm talking about
emotional rape emotional but have you
seen this no oh my goodness you because
the funniest part about this is how
uncomfortable Anderson Anderson right
there if you can oh my God zoom out a
little bit who's this girl yeah so this
is the late this is the girl that says a
trump raped her okay watch this go ahead
you don't feel like a victim I was not
thrown on the ground and ravish which
the word rape carries so many sexual
connotations this was not this was not
sexual for it just it it hurt it just
what it just you know I think most
people think of rape as a I mean it is a
violent assault it is not I think most
people think of rape as being sexy
what like a short break think of the
fantasies listen
you're fascinating to talk to listen oh
my God
[Music]
I forgot to mention one thing for you
when I read through this document right
yeah clown world [__] clown world
this woman by the way just so you guys
know when she made the allegation right
against Trump that he he raped her in
this uh in this store right out in uh
out in New York City Manhattan what she
basically did was she went ahead and
released it first in a newspaper okay
she released that part of her book in
the newspaper then she went ahead and
released the book and did a tour you're
telling me that this woman was actually
assaulted as she claims but she
conveniently go ahead goes ahead and
puts this out right before while Trump
is campaigning and also when she's right
in the middle of a book tour and the
Harvey Weinstein stuff was popping off
like come on man like perfect timing
like what what's going on and the
craziest thing is Myron people will like
they'll just say they won't they don't
go they don't dig deep right yeah
they're just like he raped her you
didn't hear he had pinned her down and
Trump raped her in some Lobby and this
is the girl like like he raped her wow
emotionally what did he do he just just
being there she felt like violated I'm
so confused that's the problem we don't
use static terms with a lot of these
liberal retards out on the left they
want to go ahead and say stupid [__]
like I feel like I was raped before he
raped me emotionally no it's penetration
against your will stupid okay that's
what it is that if you're if we're gonna
go ahead and make serious allegations
about people well we need serious
definitions on what the [__] we're
actually talking about but over there on
that side of the internet they want to
use ambiguous terms like sexual assault
and I felt this way or blah blah blah
regret is not rape but that's the
problem is that people feel like they
can go ahead and retroactively withdraw
consent and it's getting into a very
scary situation now where guys are gonna
that have any type of status whatever
you need to make these girls sign ndas
or consent forms or whatever because
they're coming after the fact 20 30. 50
years later right saying oh this
happened to me blah blah blah to go
ahead and push a [__] book yeah yeah
by the way if you show this video of
this lady again who does this lady
remind uh what's her name flavor flaves
uh no ex-wife you've seen 40 year old
virgin yeah with the the you have that
picture I sent you the one that works
the manager yeah she's like you're
fascinating I'm gonna put some blush on
you real quick I could tell she's in
another world dude the clown World by
the way what's embarrassing it's
definitely uncomfortable yeah totally
what's what's embarrassing is how
uncomfortable Anderson Cooper was
exactly and how quickly the producer
told him commercial ASAP this is
embarrassing wow and then the clips gone
viral all over the place okay and I'm
surprised the first time you're seeing
this yeah absolute embarrassing when you
see her make the argument that rapist
not physical yeah so but but she saw
books though so sometimes
so he so this is what he got in trouble
for New York and he's he's in court and
everything it's for this person this is
one of them oh my god listen their their
goal is to do whatever they can for this
guy not to run that's what their goal
it's so obvious he's a targeted attack
when I read that lawsuit and that
complaint and then saw when she filed it
she claims this happened back in the
freaking 90s yet she comes out with it
you know right before she puts out a
book and here's the other thing if you
had really been assaulted like that
right why would you take that part of
your book specifically and put it out in
the public into the newspaper to see how
people respond to it as soon as people
respond to favorably okay I'm dropping a
book and then Boom book tour right after
no one questions any of this stuff and
it's like dude is she serious but that's
why she went to a civil court versus a
criminal yeah just a Playbook an
unassailable victimhood is what we have
now that's what we have now the
unassailable victimhood you can claim
victimhood on anything and the only way
to make that work is ambiguity ambiguity
of Defense genders ambiguity of
artifactus ambiguity of what rapist and
isn't now you have unassailable
victimhood this is a Playbook ladies and
gentlemen folks didn't we talk about
this earlier the words we came up with
so qualities of the most annoying people
in the world victim oil on there
complainer ungrateful uh leechers modern
day women crab magnets what's the next
one here is entitled bitter nagger I
mean this is this is these are all
elements and qualities of that and she
shows some of those qualities so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign